the simplicity of hitting run and having
your app appear on an emulator hides a
lot of complexity
remember that Android is a full software
stack ad space is a Linux kernel which
handles low-level tasks like hardware
drivers and power management on top of
that are some core c and c++ libraries
like Lib C and SQLite and the Android
runtime that includes core Android
libraries and the Android virtual
machine dalvik or more recently art your
apps run within its own instance of the
VM using the classes and services
provided here in the application
framework on top of that sits the
application layer which includes your
app and every other app that's installed
on the device so when you hit run in
Android studio the first thing that
happens is your code gets compiled into
black code that can be run in the
Android virtual machine that then gets
installed onto the device in Android
studio this is done using Gradle a build
tool kit that manages two penalties and
allows you to define custom build logic
you can manually start a Gradle build in
the IDE by selecting make project you
can also do this by going to the build
menu and selecting make project from
there or you can use the Gradle console
to observe any logs or build errors or
open the Gradle tasks window to see any
available tasks double clicking on any
of them will execute it this all works
from the command line to once you've
navigated to the root of your project
folder you can run Gradle W tasks to see
all of the tasks that you can run you
can learn more about Gradle by checking
out the links in the instructor notes
for now note that we start with a
project which Gradle then builds and
then packages the bytecode along with
the external resources such as images
strings and UI XML into an application
package this is called an apk and it's a
specially formatted zip file once you've
got your apk ready to go it's signed and
then push to the device using the
Android debug bridge or ADB if we return
to the terminal you can see that ADB
lets you interact in debug apps on any
device physical or virtual things like
pushing and pulling files viewing logcat
output
even running a remote shell so once
Android studio has atb installed the APK
it uses ADB again to launch the app by
sending a star command by the remote
shell by identifying a package and class
name of your main activity